alors c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a
proposé de travailler par bassin de vie
puisque justement les besoins d'une
population en termes d'accès aux soins
ou d'accès à l'éducation soit défini sur
un bassin de vie intuit qu'il concerne
les nouvelles technologies c'est une
priorité effectivement et parmi les
choses que nous souhaitons proposer
c'est renforcer les obligations des
opérateurs
et là je vais céder la parole à au
président d'un conseil départemental
parce que c'était là dessus qu'il devait
intervenir et le conseil départemental
étant un opérateur justement
institutionnels favorisant les nouvelles
technologies voilà j'essaie de la parole
imprisoned conseil général merci
beaucoup on m'a prévenu qu'il fallait
que je sois bref dans mon propos est à
ce stade je suis extrêmement rassurer je
vais tenir l'engagement parce que
finalement henri bliss père a tout dit
de ce que j'allais dire alors même que
j'avais travailler consciencieusement le
sujet néanmoins il nous a décrit le
département tel qu'il devrait être
pour faire face justement à cette
redynamisation de la ruralité et en
décrivant ce département idéal j'ai cru
qu'il parlait de l'oise
si je passe mes vacances souvent dans
les pyrénées atlantiques je vous invite
à venir passer les siennes dans l'oise
et là il verra qu'on a effectivement
cette compétence de solidarité
territoriale bien ancrée dans notre
action publique et nous le faisons en
matière d'investissements sur les
infrastructures routières nous faisons
avec des plans turbo et cynisme ans mais
nous le faisons sur tout et nous sommes
plutôt département pionnier en la
matière sur le déploiement du très haut
débit
en réalité tout le monde a bien
conscience et tu l'a très bien dit de
l'importance que revêt la couverture
numérique sur le territoire et le risque
de fracture en la matière est donc
maintenant une fois qu'on l'a dit une
fois qu'on en a bien conscience comment
on fait alors nous dans l'oise et c'est
un retour d'expérience qu'on m'a demandé
de faire définitive je le fais bien
volontiers
nous avons initié en 2014 cette
politique de déploiement du très haut
débit sur l'ensemble du département il
faut juste savoir que nous avons quatre
zones dites ami appel à manifestation
d'intention d'investir qui sont des
zones denses dans lesquelles les
opérateurs viennent de même où il n'y a
pas d'engagement de fonds publics
parce que ce sont des zones assez
rentable et tout le reste du terrain
histoire en revanche et bien c'est le
désert et donc pour à peu près 400 mille
foyers dans l'oise nous en avons 120
milles qui relèvent de ces quatre zones
denses et puis tout le reste
c'est-à-dire 280000 qui relèvent de ces
zones ont pour l'instant il n'y avait
rien eu prévu jusqu'en 2014
donc nous avons mis en place un plan
très ambitieux de déploiement du très
haut débit par la fibre optique avec
câblage jusqu'aux maisons ce qui
représente juste que vous ayez des idées
des sommes 250 millions d'euros
d'engagements nous allons tenir
l'engagement nous avons même accéléré
avec la nouvelle majorité que je conduis
le défi qui était celui de déployer le
très haut débit sur l'ensemble du
département
à horizon 2020 il faut savoir que la
différence de coût entre ces zones dans
lesquelles nous intervenons parce que
les opérateurs ne vont pas et les zones
denses sont tout à fait sensible
le coût moyen d'une prise dans les zones
vraiment rural c'est aux alentours de
750 euros 750 à 800 euros c'est quatre
fois moins dans les zones denses or ce
sont dans ces zones rurales où il ya
évidemment les opérateurs qui ne veulent
pas aller et puis là aussi où l'adsl est
le moins répandu est donc aujourd'hui
alors que nous avons lancé ce plan de
construction en 2014 avec une
accélération évidemment ces derniers
mois pour tenir l'engagement de 2020 on
a déjà le retour d'expérience d'environ
28 à 30 milles prises qui ont été posées
et qui viennent éclairer évidemment ce
que tu disais c'est à dire la nécessaire
obligation de couvrir le territoire le
plus rapidement possible ensemble du
territoire
parce que c'est vrai que les témoignages
sont nombreux d'agriculteurs de médecins
qui croule sous les télédéclarations
avec parfois des programmes qui sont de
plus en plus lourd et qui sont parfois
avec du 512 k il y en a même qui disent
aller plus vite du temps du minitel ça
je sais pas on a plus de minitel dans
l'oise nous depuis déjà de nombreuses
années fait j'imagine chez vous aussi
néanmoins retour d'expérience très clair
aussi avec le déploiement du télétravail
dans nos zones rurales
et puis même création et ça s'était
plutôt inattendu de télécentres parfois
dans certains bourgs et qui relance
évidemment le dynamisme commercial dans
ces centres bourgs bref tout ça pour
vous dire que évidemment les propos que
tu as tenu sont frappées au coin du bon
sens c'est un enjeu majeur pour le pays
de procéder à ce déploiement le plus
rapidement possible nous en avons
l'expérience dans l'oise on peut le
faire
ça nécessite selon moi bien sûr qu'on
trouvait qu'on puisse mobiliser de
nouveaux fonds parce que les enjeux sur
le plan national sont gigantesques et 20
à 30 milliards d'euros d'investissements
qui va falloir réaliser pour couvrir
l'ensemble du territoire et pour ça il
faut mobiliser sans doute à travers
d'ailleurs les crédits qui avait été
prévu dans le grand emprunt mais il va
falloir aussi et tu l'a très bien dit
jean-louis qu'on met aussi les
opérateurs face à une certaine
responsabilité dans la couverture
intégrale du territoire voilà j'espère
que j'étais break